one from behind that's where rooks are  most active when they are behind  past pawns but uh yeah magnus now  has had to make the white rook very bad  white's rook  has to stay on that one square  protecting both of its pawns and  meanwhile nakamura  yeah he will just wait he doesn't need  to do anything look black's rook now  on his perfect square behind white's  past porn and he can do anything now  nakamura he can even push the blackboard  he can just wait with the black king  magnus has no way to keep both of his  pawns alive yeah okay so now  hikaru has lost one of his pawns and now  hikaru has to be  very careful where he puts the king  um yep okay so he's gone to the center  and uh now the position has fizzled out  king versus king no way that can be  a winning position no more checkmates  would magnus carlsen resign  or not resign but you know agree a draw  even against me with king against king  you have to